okay first of all how are you guys
sleeping how are things for you let's
discuss
I I'm sleeping like a baby but I'm
occasionally doing that thing where you
wake up in the night having had an
amazing dream and you think that's good
I can use this and then you think oh
I'll remember this and then you wake up
in the morning and all you remember is
waking up in the night going ah that was
story worthy so and when I was writing
Sandman of course I had the little
notebook by the bed and I would make a
point of writing the things down oh my
goodness I love to hear it I'd love to
hear about you how are you sleeping I'm
okay I'm a little I'm nervous and
excited I every day it's like the 12
Days of Christmas because every day I
wake up and I find out Netflix has
released a little bit more in the public
sphere today there are two exclusive
scenes on ign.com and so you I which I
should have known were coming out but
now people are seeing it and you know I
I wish they could just watch all of it
and and I'm excited for people to see it
but I you're right it's a tense time
it's a tense time um what is your life
like I am just so curious because you
have such an amazing imagination but
what inspires you where these ideas come
from normally the best thing is boredom
yes um getting getting bored and then
just sort of
starting to play in my head and go for
little walks in my head is actually the
best thing I recommend when people say
you know what inspires you
um middle grade drama
and middle grade concerts I think where
you cannot leave because you are there
for this whole thing
um but yeah you know you you are
desperate to get out of your seat so
that's the point where I will plot
amazing things Andrew
scares you
uh the idea of something bad happening
to my kids oh that I think scares me
more than anything else in the world you
know I'm fairly good with with rats
snakes I'm even fairly good with spiders
if I have to but the idea of something
happening to my kids and I'm a puddle oh
that's sweet except you don't want to be
at the place that's adorable we love
that at least you know your kids are up
there and they're safe and they're safe
yes so currently I've got them locked
into the attic they can't leave
they've got cameras on them from all
directions they're under lights 24 hours
it's not true I'm just making that up
you know imagination um for you adapting
yes you know one of the things fans were
talking about because the the fan base
is very passionate when we're switching
you know roles when it comes to gender
and race
what would be your response to them when
they question why that happened well
Neil has the best response
well it it was actually a function of
can we increase the number of actors we
see for for a given role does the
librarian of the dreaming have to be a
white male if if there are no plot
reasons for that why can't we see all
genders why can't we see all Races in
which case a talent pool just opens up
and you can actually find Vivian
hashempong who I I now can no longer
imagine anyone else ever playing this
role and when I go back and read the
comic it's viv's mouth viv's voice that
comes out the word balloons as I read so
so it was it was a lot of that of like
look at just examining every facet of
Sandman and saying how can we open this
world up how can we give the fans more
of what it is they love so and a lot of
the time you know we look at the comic
and go okay here is a character who is
this
do they have to be that and the answer
would come back yes you know here is
Harry the violinist
um does he have to be an old white man
that and it's like well yeah he does
he's Jewish he says to say this he's
that great he stays yeah but there will
be other roles where we would go is
there any reason why
um if the answer came back no then we
would see everybody in the auditions
which doesn't mean that we cast
people you know it means that we would
just increase the talent pool enormously
of people we were looking for casting
Cain and Abel
um
there was weirdly I I think no
intention going in to go great we will
have Asian Indian descended people as I
came and Abel
um we were looking for a fabulous cane I
thought of Sanjeev who I'd worked with
on
um
I'd worked with him on
um good Omens yeah and Asim choudhary
was the first able audition to come
through where we went oh that's able and
then suddenly we had these two brothers
and it looks like we knew what we were
doing yeah we did not know what we were
doing and we were just looking for the
best possible people and casting them
that's awesome